foreign
a lot of people are absolutely obsessed
with their max strength that's the
maximum amount of strength a person can
produce regardless of how big or small
they are
strength weight ratio of course is how
strong you are in relation to how big
you are how heavy you are and to me this
is better for a whole number of reasons
one obviously means you can jump higher
run faster climb more easily because you
have greater control over your body
weight
beyond that a good strength weight ratio
normally means you're gonna have a
pretty good physique because you're
going to want to build strength build
muscle whilst also reducing your weight
I.E reducing excess body fat
[Music]
so you're gonna be quite lean
of course things like calisthenics
skills is also quite important
and I like it because it means that if
you should fall over you'll be less
badly hurt
I did actually hurt
and if you train for your strength rate
ratio chances are your cardio endurance
and aerobic fitness will be pretty good
as well partly because you have less
body mass for your heart and lungs to
get oxygen and blood around partly
because if you're training for this kind
of body chances are you're going to be
doing a little bit of cardiovascular
exercise as well as just heavy lifting
so how do we go about training our
strength to weight ratio and is there
more to it than meets the eye well of
course there is this is a bioneer video
of course for one we need to distinguish
between strength to weight ratio and
power to weight ratio and we're going to
get to that in a moment but first let's
get the obvious boring stuff out the way
if you want to improve your strength to
weight ratio then you do need to burn
fat you need to get leaner because fat
isn't contributing to your strength so
it's only weighing you down in that
sense if you want to maximize your
performance in terms of things like
calisthenics sprinting jumping then
being lighter by losing weight is one of
the easiest and most obvious ways to do
that you do that not necessarily by
cutting but by doing a body
recomposition that means trying to build
and maintain muscle mass as far as
possible whilst also cutting down on the
fat of course this is a bit tricky most
of us know that we need to be in a
surplus to optimize for building muscle
and we need to be in a deficit to burn
fat however if you hover around your
maintenance level of calories if you go
just slightly below that perhaps whilst
maintaining a whole lot lot of protein
in your diet then you should find you're
able to strip away a little bit of fat
whilst also building muscle and I've
personally found that certain movements
like the straddle planche push-up have
become easier attainable since I've been
cutting a little bit some of you guys
have commented down below that you've
noticed I've got a little bit leaner
thank you very much for that if you'd
like to know how I did it then patreons
can get access to a guide to bodybu
composition and that also includes some
of my favorite meals recipes and tips
for burning fat and building muscle or
maintaining muscle at the same time what
I will say though is that you do need to
be very careful here because obviously
when you're in a calorie deficit or only
just at maintenance this also makes it a
little bit harder for you to recover and
it reduces your energy levels it
depletes glycogen stores in other words
you're not going to be able to train
quite as hard when you're in this state
and again I've also found this to be
true I've injured my elbow recently
which the last time I remember injuring
my elbow was the last time I got really
lean so there you go no big deal I know
how to rehab it quite easily I've done
it before but it's a nuisance and it's
something to keep in mind
so what am I on about when I say there's
a difference between strength to weight
ratio and power to weight ratio well one
way to think about this is whether you
want to be an ant or a grasshopper now
I'm not having a stroke basically an ant
can lift several times its own body
weight I'll probably put the exact fact
here on the screen while a grasshopper
can't do that as far as I'm aware but
they can leap extremely far and fast so
if you want to be someone who's small
but has a massive bench press a massive
squat then you have a good strength to
weight ratio however if you want to be
somebody who is really explosive can
leap high in the air maybe do tricks
maybe do really powerful punches maybe
you're fast that is high power to weight
ratio there is a difference between
these two things and there's a
difference in the way we train them so
we need to talk about that as well so if
you want to build strength weight ratio
you can't just focus on building muscle
because although you will get stronger
as a result you will also get heavier
muscle actually weighs more than fat so
beyond just getting bigger what we also
need to focus on is getting more
efficient so we can use that muscle more
effectively
so what it comes down to is
intramuscular coordination and
intermuscular coordination intramuscular
coordination being your ability to use
the maximum contraction you have
available to contract as much muscle
fiber as possible into muscular
coordination being the ability to
contract the muscles in the right order
and with minimal over spill you want
reciprocal inhibition meaning that these
surrounding muscles and the antagonist
muscles are not all just seizing up also
tensing because that signal is kind of
muddied instead of adding muscle first
we want to make the most of the muscle
we already have intramuscular
coordination I.E neural Drive I.E muscle
fiber recruitment is something you can
train by performing your max lift or
close to your one rep maximums if you do
a very heavy deadlift bench press or
barbell squat what you're doing here is
you're pushing against such a powerful
weight that you have to send the
strongest signal possible from the brain
from the motor cortex all the way across
the neuromuscular Junction into the
muscles that you're going to be training
this in other words you're using it and
not losing it the more you practice
sending a strong signal to the muscles
the stronger that signal can become and
if you focus on that then you'll be
building your strength weight ratio as
long as you're not also getting a lot
heavier which if you're using lower rep
ranges and having longer rest times you
won't be as inclined to do because
you're not getting the metabolic buildup
you're not creating that much muscle
damage obviously you are you will build
muscle but not to the same extent you
would do with a more hypertrophy focused
routine there is another way to train
that neural drive and that maximum
strength though and a great way to do
that is with overcoming isometrics I've
talked about this on this channel plenty
of times I won't go into it in Great
depth now but suffice to say that
overcoming isometrics are pushing or
pulling against an immovable Force
something that will not move so instead
of doing a bench press you might instead
just load the bar up with more weight
than you can move and push against it as
hard as you can normally for about six
seconds so it looks something like this
and the reason this is so effective is
because once again you're trying to
recruit the maximum strength you can
you're practicing sending the strongest
signal possible unlike an actual bench
press or other heavy lifts though you're
doing this for the entire duration of
the exercise it's only said to affect
about 30 degrees of the joint angle so
you might want to do a few different
positions or just use it to work on say
your weakest points in a movement but
this can be a powerful tool and you guys
know if you watch this channel regularly
that this is something that Bruce Lee
used to build strength and we all know
that he was a guy who was extremely
strong for his small size guys if you'd
like to learn more about this then I
highly recommend a channel called No
Limit Squad look for the bare
necessities the simple Bare Necessities
forget about your worries and your
stripes I think I've got fleas
so for this video I've been wearing the
motor strength from Vivo barefoot today
sponsor
a bit of background for those who don't
watch regularly Vivo Barefoot make
barefoot shoes that means they have a
wider toe box less of a heel to toe drop
and a thinner sole so you can feel the
ground underneath your feet your toes
can splay out within the shoe and in
general it allows you to use your foot
the way that nature intended so that you
can exert maximum power on the ground
and gain maximum stability these are
also sometimes called minimal shoes and
the motor strength is the first ever
minimal shoe that's also a weightlifting
shoe it's designed to provide you with
all of those benefits are just listed
but it also gives you more stability and
support for lifting heavy weights so
whether you're doing a deep squat under
a large amount of weight or whether
you're leaping around on a field you
should find it offers you everything you
could need and this is massive for
someone who enjoys cross training and
doing all those different things wearing
barefoot shoes forces you to learn how
to perform the movement without any
additional Aid and to regain that
Mobility at the same time because
there's no big heel you're also actually
more stable on the floor because your
toe was playing out on the ground that
gives you a wider base Vivo Barefoot
make a ton of great different shoes
though if you want to check any of them
out then head over to the link in the
description down below and use code the
bioneer 15 to get 15 off of your order
but inter-muscular coordination now
that's different that's treating
strength as a skill that means building
the coordination between the muscle
groups and like I say creating that
reciprocal inhibition it's greasing the
groove practicing the movement over and
over again so you become better at it
you want to contract the right muscles
in the right order it should be obvious
but we often forget that simply
practicing movements makes us better at
doing them
power to weight ratio is obviously your
ability to develop power quickly this is
still to do with inter and intramuscular
coordination the difference is that
we're now focused Less on how much
muscle fiber you can recruit and more
focused on how quickly you can recruit
it your rate of force production once
again to train this you simply Focus
on training this that means you need to
focus on explosive movements moving
quickly that might mean clapping
push-ups or muscle ups or clapping
pull-ups what you just mean doing
regular pull-ups even regular bench
press but lowering the resistance not
wearing a weighted vest or not going up
to your one rep max and instead just
focusing on how quickly you can move
focusing on the bar speed this is going
to teach you to more quickly recruit the
maximum fast twitch muscle fibers that
you can to exert that force powerfully
and quickly and that's your
intramuscular coordination once again at
work when you train with those explosive
plyometric movements things like jump
squats things like clapping push-ups
what you're actually doing here is
overloading the movement as you would do
by adding weight but instead of adding
weight you're using gravity and this way
you learn to absorb that shock you build
stiffer tendons that are better at
returning that energy absorbing the
impact and returning it you build the
myotactic stretch response and you learn
to more quickly recruit that fast Stitch
muscle fiber
so before you go adding loads of weight
to your movement consider adding a
little bit of gravity or a little bit of
speed or just faster intent
and guys guess what there's also a way
we can train for explosiveness using
overcoming isometrics specifically using
a formula of a common isometrics called
ballistic overcoming isometrics or
ballistic isometrics this is one of the
coolest names so you know it's going to
be a cool technique what you're going to
basically do here is to get once again
against your immovable object and this
time you're not just going to hold a
maximum contraction instead you're going
to relax and then explode into that
maximum contraction
and then you can do this
for reps this technique is used by arm
wrestlers because they need to explode
when they begin a competition as well as
a bunch of other sports people and it's
something we can use to create more
power more quickly what we also want to
think about again is our intermuscular
coordination that means thinking once
again about the order of muscles firing
and how they fire and about the
reciprocal inhibition we talked about
earlier in other words once again it
comes down to rehearsing the movement
whereas this time it's less likely to be
about which muscles contract at the same
time and more likely to be about
Contracting the right muscles in the
right order and relaxing the others lots
more comes into play here as well things
like tendon strength for example things
like Mobility you want to be able to get
down deep into a deep squat if you want
to build that myotatic stretch response
if you want to teach the tendons to be
able to absorb impact and then fire it
back
there's loads more that goes into it as
well things like your tendon strength
your pin and stiffness because you want
to be able to absorb impacts and then
return it back like that there's
Mobility because you need to be able to
get into those positions that allow you
to launch explosively out of them and
this is also why I think it's really
wrong when people say that you don't
need to train with explosive movements
and that just training strength with
powerlifting is going to deal that for
you there's a myth that fast switch
muscle fiber is entirely genetically
determined like your ratio faster which
is slow twitch muscle fiber this is
inaccurate it's about 50 determined to
buy genetics but at the same time it's
beside the point because it's not just
about building fast twitch muscle fiber
it's also about learning to recruit
those motor units quickly about sending
that signal to explode out of the bottom
of a squat finally one more thing we
should consider is that strength to
weight ratio and power to weight ratio
are both things that are localized not
Global or system-wide and what do I mean
by this
well you could be someone who has a very
explosive high jump but who can't throw
a powerful punch there's obvious reasons
for this because you've practiced that
movement specifically of course
increasing your drive to one muscle
group won't necessarily increase your
drive across the board which is why like
I always preach you need a wide variety
of different movements and different
planes of motion but even more simple
than that some people who are really
interested in calisthenics for example
and particularly moves like you know
muscle ups and clapping pull-ups they'll
intentionally leave their legs
relatively small they don't want to
build too much muscle there because that
actually makes them heavier in the legs
they unique the muscle in the upper body
but the legs just slow them down in
other words then you need to think about
what you really want and design your
body in a very conscious and intentional
manner do you want to be someone who's a
tank a massive strong tank and you don't
care about your weight or do you want to
be Spider-Man able to LEAP high in the
air and do cool tricks it really depends
for me the answer is always to be
somewhere in the middle and I also don't
want to leave any stone content meaning
I'm not going to allow certain areas to
lag behind in the others all I've really
wanted you to take from this is to go
into your training with that kind of
intentionality to think about how you
want to perform and how you're going to
train to accomplish that by the way guys
thank you so much for watching this one
if you have enjoyed it or found it
interesting please consider subscribing
I'm nearly three quarters of the way to
a million subscribers now there'll be a
huge personal Milestone to make it to a
million so I really would appreciate
that push as a lot of regular viewers
who watch regularly and don't subscribe
and I don't hold a grudge for that I do
the same thing but I'd really appreciate
it now you're thinking about it if you
could hit subscribe it would help me out
so much if like me you like training in
a way that looks at everything in a kind
of comprehensive manner you want to
build that explosiveness as well as the
mobility as well as the max strength
even brain function and alertness then
check out my ebook and training program
super functional training 2.0 there's a
link in the description down below that
comes with an 80 plus page ebook in over
two hours of instructional video and
remember that you can get access to my
body recomposition guide and my favorite
recipes over on the patreon again highly
appreciated but either way guys thank
you so much for watching this one and
I'll see you next time bye for now